I lost my dad to cancer in 2013. and he
was my greatest champion biggest fan
like
gregarious laugh loudest in the room you
know just confident Guy and
um there was a lot of Silence after I
lost my dad in my life
my dad comes from us you know middle
class background so does my mom ambala
conservative background but he always
asked for my opinion and not in a
flippant way here so let's see what a
four-year-old has to say but in a
serious way and that always made me feel
like
I'm important
I think I was very lucky to have an
upbringing where my parents gave me a
sense of self
where I was given the ability to make my
own choices I think a lot of girls
especially in our country and you know
many others their their ability to make
choices is taken away from them so I
think it's very important for us to
raise Bold Girls for us to raise girls
that push the envelope for us to invest
in the girls in our communities in our
countries because once a girl stands on
her own feet she not just takes her
family forward she takes her community
forward which in part takes the country
forwards I thought that you know my new
life and this industry and my career was
the most important thing but family is
and the people around you are and having
a support system that makes you want to
step forward every single day in this
difficult ride called life you know and
that just makes it easier I'm not
someone who walks around with the ego I
believe in hard work and I think only
your work can speak for itself so I used
to walk in I took meetings I did
auditions and I got smaller roles and I
did make them bigger and bigger and
bigger and slowly it took time to be
able to get to this place I wish I
hadn't beaten myself up as much as I did
when you're young you feel like one
failure is the end of your life or one
breakup or one friendship or one fight
you feel like you can never come back
from that and I am a very intense person
in general I'm very sentimental I'm
emotional so everything affects me
energies affect me if I've hurt someone
it affects me if by deliberately or you
know by mistake if um so I think I used
to really
beat myself up when something went wrong
or when I didn't get an opportunity I
was it's my fault I must have done
something wrong and I would like to tell
my younger 19 20 year old self that you
know
life is all Hills and Valleys it's never
going to be a smooth Road you will have
up you will have down but when it's down
you will go up so when you're up be
prepared for a down and it's okay
surround yourself by people that prop
you up surround yourself by people who
are genuinely happy for you not all the
followers not like the people who you
know you think are your friends that you
may party with but the ones that pick up
your phone call at two o'clock in the
morning the one when someone is sick in
your family that will sit with you for
hours overnight you know those are the
ones you collect those are the ones you
remember and those are the ones you keep
for the rest of your life you just it
makes it easier to have the right people
in your life life throws stuff at you
and there are times when everything
feels like you're never going to be able
to get out of it like it's quicksand
every day you're being pulled down or
every moment you can't even see a sliver
of Hope and we've all been through
phases of Our Lives where that has
happened
if you sit and you should sit and moan
what you're feeling I really believe in
not pushing things under the rug when I
first started working here
um
I think that
I did not want to be the check in the
box normalizing my culture has been a
long
um walk and there are a few of us that
are doing it and culture should be
normalized because children should be
exposed to different kinds of culture
cultures the best teacher in the world
traveling around the world meeting you
know different foods that take different
forms languages
um so I think that that had been that
became my quest for a very long time and
I'm doing a lot of work where I want to
bring stories that are about my culture
my people and should be out there I know
that actors we are the faces on posters
so people give us a lot of credit but
we're standing on the shoulders of
almost like a thousand people that made
the show when we talk about diversity in
America I think we spend a lot of time
focusing on what people you know
different kinds of people people who
look different but we don't really focus
a lot on how we sound diversity is
different languages across borders it's
not just skin tones it's not just
features not just English pictures yeah
it's not English it's Hindi it's Urdu
it's so many different languages around
the world and this is true Global
diversity that's never really been done
before you know I do believe that people
are meant to be for with each other for
whatever that duration in your life is
supposed to be and I think that people
Collide because you're supposed to
create on this small short life that you
have memories that you will take forward
family and and I think that Nick and I
had through our lives like these weird
Enchanted little moments and um but it's
lovely now to have found your person
when you and you're alone and you're
dealing with what you're scared of you
can't fight it because it's in your head
and you can't fight what's in your head
but when you talk about it to someone
you trust whether it's your family
member whether it's a loved one whether
it's a therapist whatever somehow the
power goes away from it so what I do is
I defuse it and I don't have the baggage
around my feet I move on and it's done
just move on you know life is so much
easier you're so heavy you're never
going to be able to get rise above the
water you have to let it go to keep your
head above water and I like breathing
fresh clean air
I don't think circumstances are your
environment can dictate
how you feel they can contribute to it
it's up to you to decide how much you're
taking in and how much you're leaving
out this is not something again that I
knew in my 20s obviously I was somehow
doing it because I think my parents just
like my family just taught me that
resilience of bounce back up my mom says
that to me she's like you're you've
always been someone who like just
bounces up and you're like oh it's okay
it's okay it was a mistake I'll try it
again but if you treat life like that
like whenever life has been tough and
it's been tough many times it's been
almost down and out and you don't want
to get out of bed and you don't want to
see anyone I grew up
in the public eye so I kind of realized
that my best person was me I had to rely
on my skill set whenever I was nervous
or I was scared I started focusing on
whatever was the goal in that moment